STEVE: GOOD EVENING FELLOW
AMERICANS I'M STEVE HILTON TO
TALK TO YOU ABOUT THE THREAT OF
DRUGS FROM ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE.
FIRST LET ME ADDRESS THE
ELEPHANT IN THE ROOM THERE IS A
THREAT TO JOBS FROM ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE, THERE ARE MANY
OPPORTUNITIES.
A.I. IS NOT SOMETHING TO BE
FEARED BUT SOMETHING THAT COULD
BE USED TO OUR ADVANTAGE.
THINK ABOUT IT A.I. WITH A
MUNDANE TASK THAT WE HAVE TO DO
EVERY DAY THIS WILL FREE US UP
FOR CREATIVE AND MEANINGFUL
WORK, WE CAN USE THE TECHNOLOGY
TO DRIVE INNOVATION AND CREATE
NEW PRODUCTS SERVICES AND JOBS
PAID WE SHOULD ALSO USE A.I. TO
IMPROVE OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM.
A.I. CAN CUSTOMIZE LEARNING
EXPERIENCE AND PERSONALIZED
INSTRUCTION SO EVERY STUDENT CAN
REACH THE TOP POTENTIAL.
AT THE SAME TIME WE MUST ENSURE
NO ONE IS LEFT BEHIND, WE MUST
ENSURE THOSE WHO ARE DISPLACED
BY A.I. ARE PROVIDED WITH THE
TRAINEE TO SUPPORT THAT THEY
NEED TO FIND NEW JOBS AND NEW
OPPORTUNITIES.
THIS IS A REAL CONCERN FOR THE
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS WHO RELY
ON THE JOB FOR THE LIKELIHOOD IS
NOT JUST ABOUT THE POTENTIAL FOR
JOB LOSSES IT'S THE POTENTIAL
FOR JOB MISPLACEMENT, WE CAN SEE
JOBS MOVE FROM ONE SECTOR TO
ANOTHER TO ACCOMMODATE NEW
TECHNOLOGY.
THE KEY TO NAVIGATING THE BRAVE
NEW WORLD IS EDUCATION WE NEED
TO ENSURE THAT WORKERS HAVE THE
SKILLS AND KNOWLEDGE TO COMPETE
IN THE FUTURE WHERE A.I. IS
COMMONPLACE.
ONLY THEN CAN WE ENSURE THE
PROMISE OF A.I. IS REALIZED
WITHOUT LEAVING TOO MANY PEOPLE
BEHIND.
THAT EMBRACE ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE.
THAT WE DO IT RESPONSIBLY,
THAT'S ONLY WAY WE CAN TRULY
BENEFIT FROM THE OPPORTUNITIES
IT PROVIDES.
EVERY WORD OF WHAT YOU JUST
HEARD WAS WRITTEN BY CHAT GPT
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE PROGRAM
THAT COULD DO EVERYTHING FROM
WRITE POEMS TO CREATING SCRIPTS
AND THE STYLE OF ANYONE
INCLUDING ME.
GOOD EVENING MY FELLOW AMERICANS
WAS A LITTLE BIT TOO
PRESIDENTIAL AND OTHERWISE AT
THAT WAS PRETTY GOOD MAYBE TOO
GOOD BUT IT'S A REALLY BIG DEAL
FOR ANY PROFESSION THAT INVOLVES
WRITING YOUR KIDS IN SCHOOL,
STUDENTS I